[Music]
all right zach is with us in chicago hey
zach welcome to the ramsay show
thank you dave thank you rachel for
taking my call sure what's up
uh so i've been on your program for
about three years now and i am debt free
except for my mortgage um i am
thank you i am yeah no thank you
for
providing this knowledge and rachel um
the
next step here in my life is i'm getting
married in november yay
congratulations zach
thank you thank you and i have a new
problem that i never thought about
before this what kind of took me off off
guard and i don't know how to handle it
uh the the wedding is a traditional
indian wedding
and
we're cash flowing all of it mainly her
parents and my parents so that's not the
issue
the issue is they're insisting on
gifting
us a bunch of gold both of us from both
sides
my side to hers her size to us
because that's what they do is tradition
what the hell am i going to do with a
bunch of gold sitting in a safe for the
next 30 30 years because i asked my dad
dad where's your gold that you got it
from your wedding it's been sitting in a
safe deposit box for 40 years
what am i supposed to do what am i
supposed to do
well it's tradition that's my thing zach
a little bit there's like there's like a
how fun
yeah yeah it's it's it's exciting but
i'm like so how much how much do you
think all this gold will be worth
uh
i would if i was put a number on it i
mean we probably i'm gonna end up with
like fifty thousand dollars wow okay
so how long before you sell
it exactly
i mean the the problem i'm having with
it also is my family's going spending
and paying 10 to 13
on tax for buying this gold yeah you
know that's money that i don't get it's
not it's not that's not your problem
that's their problem
so i would take the gold and i would
hold it long enough to hurt as few
feelings as possible like a year
and then i would sell it turn into cash
that's simple and it's a nice gift a
fifty thousand dollar gift of any kind
that i can sell later for fifty thousand
dollars is a wonderful not hurting
people's feelings holding off until you
heard at least
something's happening i feel it i feel
it in the air
[Music]
changing before our eyes dave you're
changing oh
yeah that's it this is the ramsay show